the lady that was off Pilate is a Navy
veteran of 32 years that's right the
crew was awesome the crew and that lady
are here today those were the passengers
on Southwest flight 13 80 praising the
crew after their terrifying ordeal and
terrifying is the word
welcome back to CBS this morning about
20 minutes after the plane took off from
New York's LaGuardia Airport on April
17th one of the engines exploded debris
shot through the air smashing a window
one passenger was partially sucked out
of the window and later died it was the
first passenger death due to an accident
accident rather on a u.s. airline since
2009 so with just one engine still
working the pilots landed safely at
Philadelphia International Airport the
crew members say they cannot comment on
the ongoing investigation but there's
still a lot to talk about with them
captain Tammy Joe Schultz first officer
Darren Ellis or and flight attendants
Rachel fern heimer Sean ik Mallory and
Katherine Sandoval are here only on CBS
this morning for their first joint
television interview welcome let's Timmy
Joe and Darren you guys were in the
cockpit
when did you realize there was an
emergency I was flying and we were
passing through 32,000 feet nice day
everything was very normal and there was
a loud bang the airplane Yod to the left
kind of can skid of a car rolled about
40 degrees to the left and and started
to descend on its own so I grabbed
control of the airplane because it was
on autopilot
and with the horns going off and the
rapid decompression of the cabin it all
happening at once there was no question
that something big was going on right
then
Rachel described what was happening in
the cabin how did you keep passengers
calm well I think that we had to take
ourselves out of the equation and
realized that wasn't about us at that
moment and it was all about our
passengers so we went row by row making
sure everyone had their oxygen masks on
and we just grabbed their hands look
them in the eyes and said you're gonna
be okay
they're going to make it did you really
think that everybody was gonna be okay
at that time we had you did you really
believe that because I know as a
passenger the main thing I do is look at
the flight attendants face to see if
they look distressed if they look upset
and when you look at a flight attendant
always they always seem to be very calm
did you really think everything was
going to be okay yes we had confidence
knowing that we were all going to make
it that we have faith and belief in our
pilots and that we were all going to be
safely on the ground and we just kept
that confidence the whole way through
letting them know hey Joe when this
happens do you say I know what it is or
how long does it take to figure out what
has happened and then how to correct it
you know initially and Darren was flying
you treat the symptoms
so we obviously had an engine seizure at
least and with the rapid
depressurization it was pretty obvious
that there was an explosion as well as
the sound and so we treated the symptoms
which was let the aircraft fly it wasn't
wanting to stay on altitude so we
descended like it wanted to and and then
we just started doing the things that we
needed to do we obviously needed a place
to land
sooner than Dallas and so we found
Darren is actually the one that saw how
far away Philly was and and we agreed
that had a long runway and medical and
things like that so really you treat the
symptoms first and then you analyze the
problem and so we then we started
analyzing we obviously had an engine the
number
engine was out and rapid
depressurization and then as we
eventually were able to speak with the
flight attendants because the only time
they can communicate with us and the
cockpit is when they're either in the
very back or the very front yeah and so
they waited until I believe they waited
until they went through the cot the
cabin to make sure everything was ok
before they called us and then they
called us and told us that we had some
injury in the back as well so then we
have a medical emergency as well to deal
with so I want to ask you about that
Tammy Jo because Jennifer Reardon passed
away and I know you all have reached out
to her family tell us about that
you know the survival of a hundred and
forty-eight never eclipses the loss of
one and just from a viewpoint looking in
she seemed like a woman with a profile
of just being beautiful in in her
priorities she seems like she didn't
wait until it was convenient or easy to
love her Lord and her family in her
community and the way she invested in
her her work just seems like it's still
blessing people I think she left a
beautiful legacy she really did her
husband has certainly talked and we've
seen the funeral and her children and
you're right as happy as it is that
everybody survived most people all of us
can't stop thinking about Jennifer
Riordan and I'm fascinated by that part
of the story because when you look at
the size of an airplane window I
wouldn't even think a human being could
get through a window Rachel you know I
think we're just really thankful that we
had awesome passengers they were able to
assist us during a really difficult time
without them the situation could have
been a lot different but how is it
physically possible that she could go
out that window Tammy Jo Darrin we saw a
lot of things that day that were just
unprecedented yeah something that we had
never seen
in our aviation careers and it was just
things that you're never gonna see again
and we just had to deal with what we had
at the time Kathryn you would have only
been working for Southwest for six weeks
yes but I've already been in the
aviation industry for the last 18 years
so I already had like experience in in
the airline and so in all those years
have you ever experienced anything like
this no no and this was the first time
this crew had flown together right yeah
so how did you all know what to do and
work so well together I know it's you
told me an interesting story about all
of your discussion right before this
flight took off well when we meet the
first thing in the morning which was
from Nashville to LaGuardia we all met
in the in the gallery and talked about
the weather and and the the protocol of
Southwest is to have a morning brief so
we did that but we I tend to go a little
deeper just because people are deeper
than the weather and so we spoke about
some things that were were a little more
interesting than just the weather yeah
you guys all talked about your prayer
groups well in LaGuardia when we had a
little extra time we're up chatting and
Rachel had gotten a new Bible with room
to journal on the side and she and
Shanique and then Katherine was talking
about she was in a study of Psalms which
is where I'm I'm doing a study in Psalms
and proverbs and yeah
Darrin he's always busy in the cockpit
it's the first officer already just let
us know a little bit about his family
and so people talk when you talk about
things deeper than the weather your
family your faith you know the things
that matter to you even if they're
different it tends to bring a bond when
tammyjo shared that with me I thought
wow this was a group even though you
guys had never flown together you guys
had shared values and that was so
important in a moment
in crisis because you trusted one
another yes yeah
exactly Catherine tell us about the
passengers I mean they their reaction in
in helping Jennifer Reardon you know
just reacting to this the passengers I
mean our passengers were awesome I mean
our safe their safety was the first
priority with us and the way that we all
remained calm reflected on the
passengers they'd seen that in us
because they look and seeing how we're
reacting and the fact that we were all
calm that's what kept our passengers
together working together as well
helping each other I mean our priority
was going to each one of them and
covering them and as Rachel said we were
telling them we're gonna land we're
gonna we're gonna be ok and to make it
wider unique Shanique and they said that
there's a reason for that and I'm
curious where did all of you at some
point feel afraid we did not you did not
feel the way that it makes you unique
right there why were you not afraid well
it was the peace that God had they're
giving us on I mean it's a peace that
surpasses all understanding and like
Tammy Jo said we came together
beforehand and we all talked about God
and not knowing what was going to happen
minutes later God had already prepared
us without us even knowing but I want to
I want people to really get an
understanding of how bad this was
because you were saying it's really loud
in that cabin her give me an example I
cuz I listened they're very degrees of
loud how loud was it and how did you
communicate when it's that loud for us
you have to really paint a picture for
us we really we didn't have to
communicate verbally with each other
because we just had trust and we were
able to just do what we needed to do but
to communicate with our passengers we
had to have a very loud Stern but caring
voice to make sure that Wednesday what
would you say Rachel I would just grab
their hands even if I had to stretch
over into the window seat and I would
just look into some of their bloodshot
eyes and say look at me we're going to
be okay we're going to make it we are
going to Philadelphia
we were here together and I think that
was the most important thing was to just
even though our ears were had popped
from the rapid decompression and there
was wind and debris all throughout the
cabin in the midst of chaos you have to
just look at someone and I think eye
contact was the biggest communication
during that Wow Wow we're gonna we're
gonna keep with this story all of you
will be here the crew of flight 1380
will stay with us ahead we'll hear their
thoughts about returning to the sky but
first a check of your local weather